do we need to like make mark be in
charge so we can do his lowly new
bequests
don't talk about my lowly noob quests
mark you lowly new but I'm not a lowly
news please you relentless my bish pleb
yes plan good word yeah I am an expert
gamer if I'm good at one game I'm an
expert at another game this is another
game I am an expert at it therefore you
can say nothing
you bring your tetris dominance over to
dauntless thank you for acknowledging
how good I am at Tetris I will bring it
over to dauntless and anyone at home can
bring dauntless home to them if they
follow my link in the description my
link in the description
not bobber waves link my link that's not
even the right link on it play dauntless
cop / r / markiplier gets you this game
what they said put lord minion 777
because it's a shorter easier to type
family-friendly fun name wait said
except my name cuz that's actually true
about my name yeah all these weird
numbers and symbols numbers in their
username yeah who puts numbers remember
seven years ago and you were like Lord
many seven said I was like now you
should probably come up with a new one
without numbers really gross okay it's
not going anywhere
[Laughter]
yeah well now you're a loser with 1.5
million subs on a stupid channel we
appreciate dauntless for sponsoring this
video you know yes we do we do so they
should use my link hey can we kill a
monster look enough this villain our
leader why buy the party leader cuz you
have the new quest what does that mean
no talk to the question mark alright
all right Catherine Sorel greetings
slayer thanks for you slay bro lastly
family friendly
I appreciate the save and I won't mince
words you're kind of handsome Wow
I think she likes me she says that to
all the Slayers a full set of Ramsgate
recruits weapons forged from ostians
steel we'll need them to get started on
the lesser behemoths Dean ste yeah you
can equip whatever weapon you'd like in
your loadout you need better protection
Oh Katerine sir I saw valve geez
remember her being that flirtatious oh
she loves me she was way flirtier with
me I feel like she said my name three
times and sent me away why men I don't
know what that's about that's weird she
was all I don't know what the deal is no
no no no she liked me even more she
liked mark yeah well know about that she
liked me a lot kind of mad whenever I
walk over no she was like giving me
smooches the whole time she was like
thank you for saving my life
thank you Lexie and listen I need you to
make me look good really good no don't
talk Lix you don't listen to them just
make me look pretty
focus licks in put a beauty filter over
my face more beauty beauty fuller so
where we going we're how do I get my
weapons so you want to talk to all
people that have question marks that is
true you want to talk to Marcus you want
to talk to the flirtatious lady I'm
gonna talk to her Gary oh the hunt chess
flirtiest lady I know oh Awards I want
that ball of fury though I do want that
ball of fury from number five elite
number five elite ball of fury oh I
don't know what it does but I want it
you think it actually works
no it's an emote hey got you go both
fall in a ditch their emotes and other
games that work
- Team Fortress 2 the emotes can kill
people huh you know you didn't get
weighed pattering soul L so that's too
soon how about that yes that's really
that's mean maybe no been mean to me
Maura
look at her shoulders oh yeah she could
squeeze my brain to mush with those look
at those arms
oh my god Moira I don't like the way
you're saying that my okay I'm gonna
craft something Wow
you might need to give some extra room
in that armor well I'm harder than
ostian steel guys oh man wow that's a
dauntless joke what hunt are we going on
first I need to make sure I have the
right like weapons I don't have any
weapons yeah well with my sweet black
and red ember main how do I that's just
like my upper blade how do I access my
like inventory hit start and then go to
load outs I am on a keyboard I got it I
got I got it I got I got a bunch of
Power Cells I'm putting in here what
does that mean wouldn't you like to know
you noob I Bry I dunno I was just
testing you'll have to kill some
behemoths if you want to know I'm gonna
kill some behemoths you'll have to I
will
well good maybe I already did I doubt it
you shouldn't ever remain you can change
your situation
pretty cool that's what I'm wearing mark
you wanna wear the same stuff is me cuz
I'm your teacher what the Master Hunter
and you are my student who's the party
leader huh
here we go you guys ready here we go
blaze behemoth here we do it we're doing
it we're doing it do it I am NOT the
party leader weapons is blaze behemoths
through Layton here we go okay
finding hunt finding the top players
safe finding hunt
wait what does what does it mean finding
Slayers we're all together Oh a blaze
weapons are bad against it you want
blaze armor and you want frost weapons
oh dear
Oh are we doing this like open or are we
doing this private Wow I don't know mark
how do we do private I don't know how to
do this that's the man you the party
leader I was trusting you there's no
option to do private that's found what
does that mean who's Mik noodle where's
Bob
I'm coming oh no it's my noodle gonna
talk don't talk Mik noodle how do you
mute someone you have to go into chat
and then select them and then I don't
know I'm playing on the controller so
none of my instructions I got it muted
okay boys hope we're on open mic so this
were in a person is just like sweet
Loudoun I have Wow what a douche
lightweight flowing from my fingers all
right let's do this get the blues what
blues why blues
okay hey what is this I'm getting
Slayers boons
I'll get your boons and grabbing the
boons I got I'm in the hunt I'm killing
it I'm Party leader dude what's you it's
both of us look this is my boy oh I'm
seeing some damage numbers I like
numbers oh I am just kicking teeth in
kicking ass can I say ass that's a TV
that's a TV word that's fair whoa I
looked impressive whatever that was
really thank you come off no I think I
did that one can we cut parts off I
don't know what
now when I wanted I'm on his tail I want
I got dibs on the tail money each tail
I'm gonna consume it to gain its oh my
god you cut off its tail shape cheese oh
my sweet Jeeves
can I cut off the head off the head
would be would be useful its vulnerable
get it right in his face let's really
like gang it up on something oh shoot
yeah good job there dad I think we got s
plus plus plus plus is all we did my
rank is a C but the team rank is an S
Plus I feel judged
I feel judged hey nice scrub weapon wait
oh thank you yeah real real silly yeah
you're uh you're taped handle looks
cooler than hey this is where my this is
my banner location I have dibs on this
oh sorry excuse me you're standing right
in my studio right here skidooed circle
is entirely claimed by I'm sorry you're
not even in the middle of the circus
good douche that's the center of the
circle oh yeah oh yeah your party leader
will take care of this guys don't you
worry about a thing oh thank god yeah
yeah I know don't worry I got it all
right recruits sword wow that's pretty
cool see everyone's going for all this
fancy crap it's really the simplistic
things
the recruit sort is really what you want
yes I didn't know that I didn't think
about that that's so it's fair I suppose
not know if you're I want to make a
raging Nasir I want to make just killed
a lesser amber man so you should be to
make some and remain stuff right yeah
but I don't look stupid
all right I'm gonna make a rage in
judging your appearance never mind
found some cool whoa-ohh likes what you
do in there bud okay man
oh I got a good thing a gathering gather
and you see my new no don't talk to her
get her in yeah it's pretty cool yeah oh
babe I would I would I just gotta I
gotta go on a mission with these noobs I
feel like you know dauntless and flaunt
let's rhyme and I'm gonna flaunt all
over these monsters I think you're gonna
flaunt yourself to sleep just let them
have with me I'm asleep from your your
I'm I'm pretty much asleep from you
talking okay I was waiting for the
insult to get good and never quite did
because you're not smart enough to
understand how good my insults oh can we
call a lesser dress that would complete
one of my big quests that would complete
dope if we could do that okay that's
weapon over Lessard Rask private hunt
got it I did it private hunt good work
bro dude who's the man oh boy I'm ready
I'm pretty probably pretty much ready oh
god another one okay I got to mute this
the Lord minyak God muting that guy
what's this thing weak to electric it's
weak to me hitting it in the face
[Laughter]
probably
yeah mark is strong enough to hit it in
the face
it's afraid of short people so it's
winked mark heading in the face right
listen guys I don't stand a chance
because we're tall and awesome
what is the deal my shirt mark where'd
you get it the pleb store yeah I did
yeah on the way to getting you your a
tomorrow your career at the discount
store
yeah cover way he won't he won't he
won't just like his channel won't yeah I
got him that's just harsh an hour's rest
me in the place that pain comes to I
don't regret it man I don't I don't
regret it at all the pain brain
I don't wear like this flare that's my
flare oh you're behind me you hold your
emote wheel and then do upwards you
shoot flares so we can find each other
better than mark over here you don't
know where I'm kind of pleb in my ear
asking me about how do I do basic thing
dude wait who is it Wade you know it
excuse me excuse me this mine spines
mine
thank you Mayans mind I got it's all
mine saw mine ominous tone a I'm very
good the bad guy where fire flare flares
over here help
alright on the way Bob where are you oh
Jesus I'm the water just shot the flare
off I'm out of stamina a new mistake
stop that I'm gonna chop your arm off I
give you some help I'm bad at dodging
how do you dodge uh be on our Gary board
and I'm not so I'm not gonna I don't
have any keyboard shortcut oh yes space
that's easy
oh I didn't even know you could die oh
yeah I forgot this guy likes to swipes
left and right
he's like a yeah funny oh did you see it
oh my god I just took a tail of the face
bark to it oh I did I did something do
that oh wow piercing knocking that tree
over look out oh Jesus both mark no I
mean I was faking it so you didn't feel
so bad when you were by yourself
I forgot to dodge because I'm a very big
expert oh my gosh tail boys Wow hell
yeah I'm gonna get this front left leg
tell you what what I I was doing like a
bajillion pokes before but now I'm not
not doing as many pokes yeah you got to
hit those combos what is I
how whoa oh he's upset he's really upset
you guys ready for me to overdrive him
again oh yeah oh yeah let's freakin
uh-oh I am tearing him up more than any
monster has ever been torn oh you're not
getting away from me that easy baby yeah
not that easy for me either baby that
easy baby
not easy baby baby oh oh thank you guys
I meet give me some credit your dad job
mark thank you plus this time I got an S
all right we got all the we got the
cover the whole ass to ass plus we got
all of it we did it we did it so you
know why I was lying I was the last one
to the fly that's how I was middle right
maybe you should have been faster dad I
said if anyone at home wanted to play
this game they can use the link at the
top of the description down below slash
markiplier I don't know the core breaker
is but here I go yeah I want some of
that
Oh fleet-footed how many cores to use
that's too bad this guy doesn't have any
cores Bob last surpise you got a sling
wheel and remains Andrea drafts not the
little baby ones so you guys got you
just how do I kick you out of the guild
I don't think we got him anymore by
guilt
all right killed no blame it's not your
fault
I'm on it I wouldn't you from the
skillet how quick you in the teeth kick
you right from this party the leader of
this guild I'm the leader for this love
this party I'm the leader of this party
I could kick you work for
a guild leader make me guilt make me
guild leader you won't you wouldn't dare
Thank You party leader I'll do it I
don't make me I'll just pass it to Bob
you can't you don't even know like
they're your party leader now what are
you gonna do oh holy the guns oh wait
guys I'm learning how to craft guns over
here hang on this game
yeah there's range weapons I want a guns
lost guard show into deal ten thousand
damage with your austin repeaters using
empowered shots and ability heck yes bro
that sounds pretty cool your allies I
made you party leader man my dress Karma
I could upgrade my desk
yeah but I could upgrade my recruit
armor oh please tell me you didn't I did
mines max power 200 crafts from Grenada
is wait are you going for dress Burma
I'm wearing amber man
are you gonna make dress cuz I'll make
dress I need more oh wait I've got
plenty stuff redress corpse what was I
looking at I can make some it mean I can
make some better dress armor no I'm
making it already stop don't
- I can make some dry I did it already
you're too late happened an upgrade some
dress Carmer yeah too late nerd wait
wait stop stop right where you are stop
right where you are stop right where you
are
look at your stupid armor and then look
in my armor a scud douche I'm better
than you I like that one what the hell
what you pointed at me you pointed me
right I pointed out wait why cuz it's
red yeah agreed
what the best color for things obviously
whatever I mean no one here is green
guys who invited
No Green is leg no okay all right guys
you're really giving me the business
here stop it what's the next what's the
next quest my lads
because mark up and promoted from the
baby monsters to fighting some cool
tough look I'm not the party leader you
are why am I the party leader I can't
make anyone else party later bob was
just promoted to party leader and said
okay he's party leader
cool cool cool I know what to do about
that do you I go to the bounty board
right yeah yeah yeah yeah hey listen
buddy I need a frost beam if you can
just like get me why don't roll
behemoths and tera behemoths but because
I love you it really be chill I'll do a
lesser Boreas and get a private match
wait wait wait wait wait what what what
it's not private how do I make it
private I messed up too late a straight
goofed ruined it believe in this party
I'm outta here Ken I'm already
matchmaking how do I stop matchmaking I
left the party I left it I didn't yeah
we both left the party Bob wait but now
I'm just I'm stopped looking I didn't
solve the problem at all I can abandon
it okay okay thank you make it a party
invite you guys the party oh all right
so you want a frost behemoth but you
want it to be a prime from so long I
changed my loadout absolutely not
so your stupid red armors not gonna make
it this time is it stupid I'm doing that
my weapon power is only 84 can I can I
power them up in 40 seconds no I mean
armor dude I just upgraded literally
everything I'm going to crush this I'm
using a weapon I've never used before
I'm like hey I've got the same weapon oh
no wait no I don't you're dying guns bro
I got repeaters call me gun daddy I will
not I'm not
please only call me gun daddy from here
on out in our personal relationship I'm
not going to miss my birthday this week
I would like you to send me a card that
says happy birthday gun daddy
nope I don't recognize the sovereignty a
birthday you don't reckon I do it I
don't recognize the sovereignty of your
birthday I'm not even sure what that
means I don't recognize me in this
outfit look --look I believe the things
I believe you believe the things you
believe and I just don't believe in your
birthday do you guys believe in my
birthday no oh there's a monster hey
guys over here
I see them going forth I'm charging it
you're charging it we have together
sweet material you're talking about this
thing's gonna be done by the time you
guys get here you guys gather up
whatever you need to gather up listen
you let's be rad II you really get in
there can you shoot a flare up or
something where where are you right now
hey buddy don't coming
marks hitting it that's kaduche miss me
oh this guy's are real bad at this game
oh I apologize but I'm gonna kill this
guy super fast I'm just so awesome all
right it's kind of blue very blue hey
he's got babies babies yeah kill kill
them kill them babies now they're all
going for Mark I'll go for him why
they're going for me stop this how do I
use a health potion I don't remember how
to do that there's someone there bottom
right you should see if you have one
equipped it'll be one of the d-pad
buttons yeah how many times have I said
I'm using a keyboard ah I've got it if
you killed a baby
it makes you stronger against the dead
II I know I've been killing the babies
oh boy oh he's red he's not happy now
yeah whatever I'm not happy either how
do I use my my Spears oh missile
launcher anybody know how that works
definitely definitely okay yeah it's the
invincible right now no no he's vincible
whoa
to death here a thousand twenty-eight
damage on him I don't know wait how do
you do that wait how'd you do that well
I use the controller alright okay I'm
gonna go into the keyboards don't let it
kill me oh you killed it guys
oh I just threw a grenade it I was gonna
I was gonna get them guys over here oh
wait I can't use my flare right now I
don't know how to do the D yes double
plus s plus plus plus plus with like an
extra star buy it to show that mine was
better than mark oh what an absolute
sham sorry Bob I just I'm too good at
this
Oh bless my stars well if only I got
fans out there for using my link you
might MyLink scription now mine's right
at the devil sword minute 7 7 7 s + +
star no listen great these people are
well aware that I was way better than
you and they're gonna use my legs good
that's cute you okay alright maybe bust
a blood vessel or two with that laughs
bother than that I'm fine alright well
hopefully was worth it
it really wasn't but like for the sake
of everything I'm gonna say it was
alright well so yeah it was while you're
in the hospital recovering uh use my
link played on let's talk I'm so smart
to have a computer there to play on
while I'm not spittle thinking smiling
wow you know but my link is technically
shorter than your like easier to
remember it takes one click either way
so it takes one click but they have to
they have to make the choice they have
to mentally be able to live with what
they've done yeah when they click on
circuits why there's certain other
things yeah and I am the chosen one
you know when they see your link it's
gonna be like all these weird numbers
and symbols and they're gonna be like
this is a virus on this but I don't know
if I can trust this this is the white
markiplier I'm the Drowned guy remember
the guy the water man
yeah he died not yet you drown hit this
the Drowned past-tense you're drunk okay
so if you stop it early you're you're
okay so your water problem she's doggone
well we hope so you didn't stop it did
you listen I'm very busy can we talk
about something else yeah my legs help
me help me afford cereal click my link
cereal yeah it doesn't need cereal he
has cereal that's a lie the average
price of a box of cereal has gone up in
the last 500 years
get some thumbs up for the for the
homies you know do we still call our
audience our home absolutely I've never
not called my audience every second of
every day I'm going them up in the
morning you owe me mumbling in my
nightmares home still cool 2019 well
you're as cool as you have ever been
hello I'm back from the future with
something very special to show you by
gregorio Flint here the hunt pass the
Hahn Pass is a way to get bonus loot and
all kinds of cool things like this
wonderful outfit right here like making
choices I'm gonna go for the bundle and
what all-in-one ought to be useful claim
rewards what did I get
Oh night hunters bike horn oh that's a
cool outfit oh it's cool oh but
everyone's gonna be wearing it oh but no
demons babe oh my god how much stuff did
I get daily Patrol bonus cool bounty
token cool which is chance listen
closely and you'll hear the drifting
through the fog what is that ghost of a
dog he keeps baring who's up for the
backyard yeah more bounty tokens Gold
Slayer core open this Slayer core the
core breaker just clicked cells that can
augment your
Geir but may put the candle back where
holy crap oh my god
oh what a hammer that's not a very
strong hammer that enters boots didn't
our to get those okay so I just got a
bajillion things and that was only the
first 15 levels skip to next level I'm
good for now the hunt pass has a bunch
of items you probably have seen passes
like this before same general principle
you level up as you play the game you
unlock as you go let's stuff I don't
know what I'm gonna do with it I could
probably try to equip some of it Oh
interesting where did I get that from
it's not even a thing that I was going
for but I'm I'm okay with it
hold on pass but it's still pretty cool
why am i Robo I'm not a hundred percent
sure but I'm a Robo I'm a Robo I'm a
robo it's my robot this is not what I
just unlocked in the hunt pass but I
don't care because it's cool didn't even
know this day and age can have robos if
we're all hunting living creatures out
in the wild unsuspecting creatures ready
for my spear so that is what's available
in the hunt pass so go check out
dauntless if you want to play dauntless
for yourself there's a link in the
description below and check out Bob and
Wade's videos on this as well there are
awesome people so go support awesome
people and if you have to use a
different tracking link I suppose you
can use theirs but you can only get it
from their video so go check them out
down in the description below thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
[Music]
you